[Music]
gets a quarter of it could resist having
pc well a tempo you will the netflix it
and called order sweeties pta behavior the
mega predator different huh production of the
final season the show has budget
challenge oil is nice storming
allegations against the as buy order
upcoming to line you're not happy with
our dynamic
a new brushing grout medical on
health of cards equo toxic in bar miriam
and how he to interact with a theory and
spoke to one on a production system
how small specific do you want to salt him
how we  wave must that actor to assess
the global network pro
he was in a stone or jaqen in estate
with netflix s honor is well again or any
other incident imbibing kevin spacey
dismayed and the production capri behine the
show seth this is deep trouble to learn
about this  new applications and its on it
and the name is complain highline
crisis counselor and sexual harassment
legal advisors for the crew the
allegations came after actor andrey
weapon cues p  c
comments and widgets actual bad george
in my new sporty grout session that's
a remember the encounter
spaces website on wednesday the actor
code is taking the time necessary to
seek and valuation and treat with the
following day ethics and warm white grout
was let go by is  publicist and that style
and agency
this may how s not to be verified do you
claim the bbc specie mead and when the
badges around him a typical teenager in
the killer weapons it was a nice
tribal knowledge about abuse by my
torso now a functional symposium was
a  crash pads and functional and sweet
my ups and downs kamp open
grout is well responding to easily be
said you say it mine effects halves
cards for say brothers of flying
above as post purple broken is crosscast
thinkers played in the site which by
boeboe fork must  storyline pot
no robin wright just be the lyre on
infernal card soon we ready for
[Music]